so good morning everybody
um my name is Aaron standard and today
we're going to be talking about uh
learning.net systems programming the
hard way and a little bit about uh sort
of my discoveries and experiences along
the way welcome everyone who's coming in
there should be plenty of seats around
here still
uh it's a little bit about me I've been
a net developer since 2005. I started
learning.net I think it was done at 2.0
had just come out I was a college intern
working for a company called the fair
Isaac Corporation they use machine
learning to compute everybody's credit
worthiness in the United States
um I also
have built a large-scale software as a
service application on top of.net it was
basically a multi-tenant real-time
analytics and marketing automation
system for Developers for building apps
for the Windows store
and as part of working on that company I
co-created akka.net and have been the
maintainer of it since about 2013 so
this November academic will turn 10 and
I've been working on it continuously
more or less
and what I'm responsible for in the well
in terms of what octodon that does if
you're not familiar with it it's an
implementation of the erling style actor
model but on.net so it's sort of a
canonical implementation of the actor
model
um this is designed for handling highly
concurrent and distributed workloads so
we deal with all sorts of system issues
such as working with with threads
working with network i o serialization
uh context switching and these are all
Concepts we're going to be touching on
in the presentation today uh the primary
thing that akka.net is used for is
building Mission critical real-time
applications so I'd give you a real
world example of that we have a lot of
customers and spaces like real-time
Fleet and Logistics tracking for cargo
networks trains ships that type of thing
we have a lot of customers that use
awka.net for running real-time Financial
systems so being able to do things like
automatically trade currency or be able
to manage positions in a big equities
portfolio and we've been used for some
more fun stuff like multiplayer video
games so given the space that we're in
performance is an essential feature of
our work on the aqua.net project and
this is sort of what I've learned while
working on that feature
the first place will kind of start
talking about systems programming is
garbage collection in.net uh the garbage
collector is going to be one of the
biggest sources of potential CPU
consumption inside your system
potentially if you're not very efficient
about how you allocate objects but on
top of that the garbage collector in.net
is highly configurable you can go ahead
and reduce the penalty that garbage
collection imposes on your application
by adjusting a couple of settings and
I'm going to show you one very powerful
setting in just a moment or by maybe
changing the way you manage the lifespan
of some of your objects
so the way.net garbage collection
typically works is let's say for
instance we have this set of memory on
our left initially right where we go
ahead and have a total let's say seven
objects in memory
and then the application forms Roots
those objects these are active
references for other objects that are
not yet marked for deletion so as long
as an object is rooted it will be
retained in memory by the garbage
collector an object that is not rooted
will be collected and its memory will be
freed and released back to the
application that's what the garbage
collection process does this tries to
identify those unrooted objects and free
up that memory
so after the garbage collector runs
there's one more important thing that
you'll kind of see on the diagram here
which is that those objects that are
arrayed in memory all get compressed
together again in memory as well this
sort of compaction of free memory is
designed to help accelerate the
allocation of new objects in the future
so the garbage collector in addition to
freeing objects that are no longer
rooted is also responsible for trying to
compact memory together that compaction
process is actually really essential for
helping make your applications fast
imagine if you had let's say a
collection of different objects that you
were working with inside some key
business context well if they're all
available sequentially together in
memory that makes it more likely that
you can take advantage of caching at the
hardware layer inside your computer it
also makes this access much quicker
because it's all sort of sequential
increments of a pointer that way whereas
if that memory was highly fragmented you
wouldn't be able to take advantage of
that and you'd see a noticeable
performance hit doing it so the garbage
collector does all this for you more or
less
we have four generations of garbage
collection in.net essentially first
as what we call gen zero garbage
collection the general the more the
higher up the the generation is the more
expensive it is to run so gen zero
garbage collection is the cheapest and
these are for objects that are
essentially ephemeral so for instance if
you allocate a string inside the scope
of a function do some work with it uh
maybe you write it out to the console
and then that function exits that's
going to be gen zero collected more than
likely and we're going to see a little
example of that in a second so that's
the sort of the cheapest form of garbage
collection and the reason why it's cheap
is that we go and allocate that object
at the top of the Heap and then
immediately take it off the Heap again
without necessarily needing to do a
complex
rooting sort of calculation inside the
GC system so it's really easy to get
stuff off the top of the Heap and uh
back again doesn't also doesn't require
any compaction when we do that
one garbage collection is slightly more
expensive these are for objects that
survive at least one uh gen zero garbage
collection attempts they get promoted
into a higher generation so these might
be objects that maybe get assigned as a
property to a class and that class gets
passed around across multiple methods
and over you know a handful garbage
collection runs uh that object is still
in use still rooted so we don't we don't
collect it right away but generally it's
going to get collected after a fairly
short period of time in gen 1. so gen 1
is only incrementally more expensive
than gen zero Gen 2 is where things get
really interesting uh these are the
long-lived objects inside your
application that have survived multiple
gen 1 garbage collection attempts
these tend to be things like
for instance if you have a static
property inside your application that's
always going to live in Gen 2 garbage
collection and in fact we'll probably
never be collected or another example
this might be if you have some objects
that are extremely long-lived so a good
example with you know akka.net and the
actorspace if you have an actor that's
running in the background and they can
run for months or days at a time that
actor in all of its state will all be in
the Gen 2 garbage collection category
and then finally we have sort of our
fourth generation here which is kind of
a special case this is the large object
Heap I'm blinking
on actually no I'm not blinking I have a
note that tells me here
um in order to be on the large object
Heap it has to be a object that is
bigger than 85k is how big it needs to
be so if you have a really large buffer
maybe you've done something like load uh
binary file from disk or maybe you have
a super big object graph that goes in
the large object Heap and that gets
created a little bit differently because
the cost of memory compaction is a lot
higher for doing that you're compacting
a lot more stuff all at once when that
occurs
all right
there we go
okay let me turn my mouse on all right
so the.net memory model let's take a
look at this little piece of code right
here so I have a this is inside a class
and I have a private read-only field
that accesses this random.shared
property a random.shared is a static
type it's built into I think this
is.net6 so that is going to be a Gen 2
garbage collected object
inside this method we are going to use
that random to generate two integers
integers are value types so they belong
on the stack they're not even going to
get garbage collected they're just
simply going to be released as this
function exits the stack once it
completes
but down below
if I go ahead and let's say add up that
integer so I you know sum those two
integers together and I convert that
result to a string and write that out to
the console here's what's going to
happen
I have my stack which basically consists
of everything that's happening inside
this function while it's executing and
some of these are going to be local
instructions that are all local to the
stack again that's not going to touch
the Heap which is what dotnet uses for
allocating you know reference types like
classes on the Heap I'm going to go
ahead and have a reference to the method
itself I'm going to have a reference
that static field and then further down
on the Heap I'm going to have the string
that I allocated while I executed this
method once
what's going to end up happening is that
this string is going to get garbage
collected via gen zero that's uh
random.shared will be in gen 2. all
those integers are on the stack they're
value types so we don't garbage collect
them at all they're just automatically
freed and this method belongs to a class
that could either be gen 0 gen 1 or Gen
2 depending on how long it lives
so for generally speaking for garbage
collection purposes from a performance
standpoint
we know that basic garbage collection
costs increases with the size of the
generation a Gen 2 garbage collection is
going to involve a lot more compaction
and a lot more memory basically reducing
a lot more memory fragmentation from a
lot more places and the garbage
collector will introduce what's called a
garbage collection pause potentially
inside possibly your foreground thread
or depending on how you configure IT
background threads we're going to talk
about that configuration in just a
second so the ability to not have as
many of those expensive Gen 2 garbage
collection Pro attempts will actually
help improve the overall throughput and
efficiency of our application so if we
can we want to try to keep our
allocations limited to either the stack
so value types or we want to try to stay
inside gen 0 gen 1. that's going to
ultimately results in the cheapest
garbage collection overall and is going
to help keep our memory less fragmented
again like I mentioned earlier in gen
zero for allocating something at the top
of the Heap and we'll talk about how the
heaps organized in a minute
if we're allocating stuff at the top of
the Heap because that's just you know
the code that's executing right here in
this moment everything lower on the Heap
is all the older Gen 2 gen 1 stuff that
survive multiple garbage collection
attempts we can allocate that string on
the Heap and then pop it right off when
that function exits and that's very very
inexpensive to do doesn't involve moving
other objects around in memory
so that's one of the reasons why it's so
cheap
now if you have Gen 2 objects the right
approach for maybe trying to help manage
performance there is keep gensu objects
available in memory forever no garbage
collection for those objects will occur
if they're still rooted this is where
and we're going to get into some
examples of this Concepts like memory
pooling and object pooling kind of enter
the picture where maybe rather than
having a bunch of new stream Builders
allocated continuously behind the scenes
maybe it's better to have a shared pool
of a thousand of them that get rented
periodically throughout the course your
application running that might actually
result in a lot less memory
fragmentation and a lot less garbage
collection over the course of your
application's lifetime
so yeah this is where we get into things
like object pools
um so I think Daniel and his talk
yesterday mentioned
um the array pool for being able to go
ahead and get uh essentially chunks of
memory you could use for working through
uh buffers and that sort of thing
Microsoft also supports arbitrary pools
of objects as well where rather than it
just being bytes it actually might be a
functional object you can go ahead and
reuse over and over again and the best
candidates for these things are reusable
types such as string Builder is the
example we're going to take a look at I
think byte arrays also work as well but
there's more specialized uh basically
pools for that like the memory pool type
and you might also be able to
um have a couple of other reusable types
for doing things like serialization
potentially but string build is probably
a really good candidate because it's an
object that can be inherently sort of
expensive to spin up and create but you
can also clear all of its state when you
return it to the pool that's what makes
it reusable
so to give you an example
this is some code from the aqua.net
project here where we are doing a Json
serialization inside akka.net this is
like our default serializer now one of
the things that we decided to do is
rather than basically allocating a brand
new string Builder each and every time
we were going to allocate up front when
the process first began a fixed number
of them I think 1024 string Builders is
what we decided by default so so we're
going to go ahead and get a reference to
a string Builder pool and just grab one
copy of a string Builder that we're
going to use right here inside this
newtonsoft.json operation
so we go ahead and pass in that string
Builder into the Json text writer down
below we call serialize and then we
convert this to a byte array and then at
the very end in our little finally block
we return that string Builder we just
used back to the pool all over again
well to give you a sense of what the
performance impact of this looked like
I have here on screen you know some
benchmark.net results from when we had
pooling no pooling and then
multi-threaded versions of both of these
benchmarks this is a theme you're going
to see show up over and over again is
that our Benchmark numbers start to
change when we start making them
concurrent that's something that we're
going to focus on as well
so here I can see that our pooled
implementation used about
49.7 megabytes whereas our unpooled
implementation used about 71 megabytes
that's a 30 memory savings on top of
that we completely eliminated gen 1
garbage collection uh period by using
the pooling system instead so that
helped quite a bit and in terms of our
Peak latency here we went from I don't
remember how many objects we were
serializing I think it must have been a
hundred thousand or so but we basically
went from doing it in about 44
milliseconds to 42 in the single
threaded scenario but in the
multi-threaded scenario
if I go down here we actually have a 28
throughput Improvement akka.net is
extremely multi-threaded in terms of its
inherent nature so that was a really
nice win for us the pooling ultimately
helped
akka.net improve its throughput for its
sort of normal standard use Case by
about 28 percent
now this is where we start getting into
things like garbage collection settings
uh the way you configure your garbage
collector can actually have a big impact
on how these changes will affect your
application
um so there's basically this sort of
little Matrix here of the three
different fundamental modes of garbage
collection uh there's background garbage
collection which has been enabled by
default for quite a long time in.net now
and what this basically does is it
allows a background thread to be
responsible for doing most Gen 2 garbage
collection that way you don't have a big
GC pause that will affect your app so
good example if you were building a Maui
application or a WPF app prior to having
a background GC enabled you might get if
your application was allocating quite a
large number of objects a visible pause
or stutter on screen while the GC
operation went through that's not a good
user experience so beginning I think
around.net framework when they enable
this this must have been like.net
framework 4.5 or 4.6 so quite a while
ago they implemented this to kind of
move all that work on the background
thread
however most audit applications by
default run with background GC enabled
and with workstation GC enabled where
what occurs with workstation garbage
collection is that gen 0 and gen 1
garbage collection typically happens on
your foreground thread meaning the
application threads that your app is
using to actually do work this creates a
garbage collection pause that while it
tends to be a lot smaller because it's
gen zero and gen 1 garbage collection
which we know is relatively cheap it
still does cause a pause inside your
system so this is kind of like a
blocking garbage collection
implementation and this is the default
that most applications use and it is
also if you don't specify the default
all brand new data applications still
used today
this is where we take a look at
server-side garbage collection now this
is going to be there's going to be two
pieces of advice during this
presentation that'll give you the most
bang for your buck you can implement it
in five minutes and it might make a huge
performance difference for your app this
is the first piece of advice like that
is enabling server-side garbage
collection
what server-side garbage collection does
is kind of by definition ideal for let's
say asp.net or grpc or signalr
applications
what it essentially does is it fragments
the Heap on a per core basis so rather
than having one big Heap for your
process that's managed by a single Gen 2
garbage collection thread and the
background GC system now you have a heap
per core inside your your application so
there's if you have a 16 core machine
you're going to have 16 little heaps
that are all managed by the CLR
what server-side GC will do is it will
essentially run a dedicated thread per
core for being able to garbage collect
each of those independently from each
other so you're no longer going to have
blocking Our Garbage Collection that
causes let's say your entire front-end
threads to potentially pause it's all
going to happen on a per core basis and
each Heap can be managed independently
by its own thread and its own set of
memory that it uses for that CPU so this
is going to greatly improve throughput
but the cost you're going to get from it
is that memory usage will be a lot
higher on average and on top of that you
might notice that the actual amount of
CPU time used by the garbage collection
process is also higher in the grand
scheme of things though the juice is
worth the squeeze
so let's take a look at an example
to enable whoops my it looks like my
annotation is missing a little bit
to enable server-side garbage collection
in case you can't see it might be a
little too small back there
um
but in case you can't see it it's this
property right here server garbage
collection is true when you enable that
that'll go ahead and cause when your.net
process launches it to run with that you
know per core based mode instead of
doing it as sort of like a workstation
mode
let's take a look at some performance
figures again apologize if these are too
small back there so this is I believe
our Aqua dot remote ping pong Benchmark
that we use this is how we test the
end-to-end throughput of like a single
Connection in akkadot remote
so I have workstation GC on my left and
server DC on the right
on the left I'm doing about
140 to 150 000 messages a second
on the right I am doing roughly twice
that I'm doing about 295 293 291 a
thousand messages a second there all by
changing one XML setting in my project
that's a lot of bang for your buck right
there so rather than having your
engineers spending an inordinate amount
of time trying to Performance optimize
things maybe just configuring your
garbage collector differently can make a
huge difference
I've got one more easy win like this for
you guys a little bit later in the
presentation
where again it's just changing one XML
setting but this is the first one so
enable server side GC if throughput is
important uh the one big trade-off here
is that if you're running let's say a
really densely packed server Farm where
you might have hundreds of multi-tenant
applications all running on the same box
this is probably cost prohibitive to
enable server-side GC for all of them
but that's kind of an unusual hosting
setup you don't see very often anymore
for most of your sort of application
workloads server-side GC is probably
worth the trade-off
now you got a question yeah
how big of so the question was how big
of a memory increase do you see when you
go from workstation GC to server GC
um
basically if we were allocating on our
heat before let's say it was uh 10
megabytes for our
um workstation GC right out of the gate
you might see that the average memory
usage might be something closer to 40 or
50 megabytes in there so not necessarily
A 5x increase because I'm also not
getting into things like page sizes and
all that the the amount of total amount
of memory increase I'd say as a
percentage it's going to be using the 30
or 40 percent more memory probably than
it did before and that's not necessarily
that the memory is actively being
utilized is that the application is
going to demand that much more capacity
in order to have Heap space available on
each core right so that's sort of like
requested memory not necessarily used
memory does that make sense yeah
would I enable this for UI applications
well as long as it's not running on a
super low powered machine uh yeah I'll
definitely go ahead and enable it
um I don't quite Recall why server side
GC is not enabled by default to be
honest with you
um but you know I don't I don't think it
would hurt again if throughput's
important I would probably enable it if
you're more concerned with let's say
keeping resource utilization as low as
possible let's say you're building a
application that's going to run on a
thin client that has a really low amount
of CPU and memory I'd probably stick
with workstation GC for that
so the question is if you're running on
containers is server GC a problem
so the question was if I tell me if I
got this right that if you're deploying
maybe we'll need to get back to that one
at the end real quick
um
now in terms of technique so we've
talked a bit about how the garbage
collector works and how it can affect
the performance characteristics of your
machine and we've seen a couple of
little examples of like how we can uh
reduce our our usage of the garbage
collector through techniques like
pooling well the next thing we kind of
want to talk about is from a coding
standpoint what are some little things
you might end up doing on the hot path
of your application that can result in
the garbage collector having to work a
lot harder than it needs to a really
good example of this and Daniel talked
about this in his excellent talk
yesterday as well is delegates and
closures inside our application
so
if we have this little bit of code right
here and again I apologize for the small
size
this is the run method of the akkadona
actors mailbox this is like the hottest
of hot pads inside akka.net this is
designed to run hundreds of millions of
times per second potentially well
we were doing a delegate call down here
on this method we accidentally closed
over the this keyword which is something
that you know we sharper jetbrain's
writer will warn you about when you're
doing that so we closed over this in
order to base the execute a little bit
of processing and cleanup code inside
this method
so I went ahead and I benchmarked this
and said okay what does our performance
look like as sort of a bit of a baseline
here and so when we're processing 10 000
messages we could do that in about 216
microseconds today and we allocate 385k
worth of memory that's just queuing up
messages and then when we schedule the
actor to actually run and process those
messages it takes about uh 2.3
milliseconds roughly and we consume 21
kilobits worth of information uh the
enqueue performance on the mailbox is
kind of a step that happens before this
well one thing we did was we simply
inlined the delegate so rather than
um trying to basically rewrite the
delegate to pass in a bunch of
additional uh stat properties then
trying to make that delegate cash and
make it static we just took a look at
what the delegate was doing and said you
know what it's not so sophisticated that
it's kind of worth it for us to and plus
this code's not callable from the
outside it's all internals
we should just go ahead and in line with
that delegates doing and just simplify
this code not avoid having the delegate
in the first place
so we moved some of the code the
delegate was doing and just kind of
copied it right here into the hot path
and here's what the performance
characteristics look like here
we went from allocating when the actor
processes messages
21 kilobits when we did 10 000 and 203
kilobits when we did a hundred thousand
all the way down to just a single
kilobit going forward and that one
kilobit probably corresponds to
something innate with the actor itself
has nothing to do with the volume of
messages it's processing and on top of
that we had a bit of a throughput
Improvement of around 10 percent uh
which really helps uh speed up your
actors by default as well so just simply
getting rid of allocating this delegate
that was probably a gen zero allocation
it's probably where it was showing up in
garbage collection getting rid of that
um on its own right kind of really
helped speed up our application reduce
memory pressure and just got kind of
waste out of the picture for this really
critical area of our framework
now there's a number of other different
ways you can go about getting rid of
delegates other than inlining them
inlining is probably what I would do if
it's really simple and it's in a really
critical area where it's being used but
if you have like a public API and you
can't necessarily easily get rid of
delegates because end user code relies
on having a callback or some other
configuration method there's some better
techniques you can use here
um see Daniel and his talk showed using
static delegates that's a new keyword
they added in c-sharp nine you can go
ahead and declare a delegate as static
that means that it's not going to be
able to close over any local context
that it's running inside of you're going
to have to pass in anything any data you
want to use inside that delegate from
the outside using parameters so that's
going to use the compiler to help
prevent you from having these types of
implicit closures and other sources of
waste so static delegates are a good
idea another thing you can potentially
do is a value delegate this is a
technique from Bartosh Adam chesky that
I really like which is a way of
basically of kind of having delegates
Without Really writing them as Lambda
expressions and let me show you an
example of that real quick
this is a private read-only struct this
request worker task right here so this
is a value type hence the term value
delegate
implements an interface called I
runnable I runnable is basically
something that's going to get scheduled
onto the occodine net dispatcher
typically it's a mailbox processing run
but it could also be something like a
scheduled task could also end up on
there so we implement this I runnable
interface and that's this little run
method down below here and this run
method will run just the same as a
reference type
what we can do in places where we are
going to consume this delegate
is we basically can go ahead and pass in
into this pool you know queue user work
item we can go ahead and pull in a new
instance of this value type here now
you'll note that I make a a note here
that we can potentially create a boxing
allocation by accident if this method
takes an object or some sort of
reference type down here we're going to
go ahead and undo the work of passing in
a value delegate reason why is that
that'll get converted or boxed into a
reference type and then executed inside
of there and we're still going to be
creating allocations so what you can't
see on this particular piece of code is
that this actually takes a generic of
type I runnable and that is not going to
create any boxing for us we're going to
be able to pass in this particular
struct and that's going to get run
behind the scenes without creating
boxing one other thing we're going to
talk about is some potential sources of
boxing that might have happened in
earlier versions of C sharp can by and
large get eliminated now through Dynamic
profile guided optimization which is the
second big win we're going to talk about
at the very end of the presentation
so value delegates are another Technique
we can use to get rid of delegate
allocations
now another source of potential memory
waste that can build up inside our
system is empty Collections and here's
something that I noticed while I was
using jetbrain's Dynamic profiler
was I noticed that our finite State
machine actor which basically sends
around some little State objects to kind
of describe here's the current state and
position of our actor at any given time
I noticed that this thing when we were
running our remoting Benchmark allocated
according to writer on here about 360
megabytes I'm thinking to myself this is
like a stupid Poco class that doesn't
have any innate data on its own how
could we possibly be allocating that
much memory on here
so I decided to look under the covers
you know what let's see if I can zoom in
a little bit
um
yeah you know what I'm going to go ahead
and call an audible here
take that 4x3 resolutions
hold on
yeah
not not letting not letting my Boomer
PowerPoint skills get the better of us
today all right
so
here's what I found inside the state
class is
some probably me
I decided to go ahead and allocate a new
list if the in the event that the
replies was blank and you know this is
back in
2014-13 when things were a lot more
innocent you know back then we didn't
know any better we were just having the
time of our lives well this allocates a
new non-empty array every single time I
create one of these State objects
ironically enough it's creating it when
there's nothing for us to actually do
it's creating a bunch of empty lists for
no apparent reason and so that is what
is resulting in this 360 megabytes worth
of whoops
well apparently I should not have
taunted PowerPoint
all right
okay
so apparently this is basically what the
source of our allocations was so every
single time you go and allocate one of
these new lists you're going to be
create putting 32 bytes on the Heap so
this is a really easy fix in newer
versions of.net because the.net Base
Class library now supports having a
static sort of generic property oops
there we go
having a static generic property called
array.empty and you can pass in the type
there that's going to allocate a 32-bit
object once per type and I can go and
reuse that every single time I spin up
one of these new state classes or every
single time I need to use an empty
object anywhere throughout my
application so this completely
eliminated that accidental source of uh
of allocations there
next in terms of something that is a
little counter-intuitive value types
versus reference types
the thing we have probably heard over
and over and over again from people like
David Fowler and other folks who are
working on asp.net performance is that
value types are the greatest things in
sliced bread you should use them
everywhere where you have sort of Val
you copy by value sort of semantics
that's going to result in a lot less
allocations a lot less garbage
collection pressure going to result in
Faster software I am generally also a
proponent of that but it can get a
little nuanced and that's what we're
going to take a look at
this is from that same class we're
looking at anaka.net this is an event
that gets emitted every time our finite
State machine has work to do so every
time someone wants to send a message to
a finite State machine actor it's going
to get encapsulated inside this event
type
so we allocate uh millions of these per
second in busy applications here and
this shows up on our profiler when we do
that
so if we take a look here let me zoom in
on my little little graph
there we go so we've benchmarked our
finite State machine actor in terms of
how much memory and how much time does
it take to process a million messages
compared to an untyped actor which does
not use these event types
well the total amount of memory we
allocated for our FSM actor was about
287 megabytes versus our untyped actor
which used roughly a fifth of that 56
megabytes
okay well that's a little disconcerting
so what if I change that sealed class
that we saw earlier to a read-only
struct functionally equivalent to what
we were doing before doesn't
meaningfully change the semantics of how
this actor works
what does our memory allocation look
like now change it to a value type
and we see a reduction of roughly 30
megabytes on our message processing here
doesn't reduce it all the way to zero
because there's other stuff that the
finite State machine actor is doing but
basically reduces the overhead of
allocating just the
um the event class by roughly it's like
32 bits a pop basically so for a million
events we get 32 megabytes total shaved
out of the allocations during that
Benchmark that's how that sort of gets
calculated so that's a little bit of
memory savings there and a minor
throughput Improvement
well one thing we decided to do is take
a look at where we are currently using
value types but we're not using them
very well inside our application this is
that boxing terminology I mentioned
briefly earlier boxing is what happens
when you accidentally cast a value type
back into a reference type it completely
undoes all the undoes all the great work
you've done uh trying to go ahead and
use value types inside your system when
you do this
so
if I take a look here
yeah boxing is basically when you
explicitly cast back and forth here's an
example of a method right here if I zoom
in some
this is inside that finite State machine
class again again we found just a lot of
stuff wrong with this class when I when
we started looking under the covers
this is a quality method right here
state name equals next state
and so quick show of hands for everybody
who believes that a referential check
for equality should return allocations
or produce allocations show of hands
all hands are down you all pass the test
good this is code smell when you see
this showing up on here it means someone
someone made a boo-boo as we say inside
our team
so 496 Megs allocated there's trouble
Brewing
so what exactly is causing this
well the issue here in fact I'll zoom in
one more time the issue here in this
case is that the state name is typically
an enum which is a value type in.net and
we are actually doing an object that
equals call right here which means we
are boxing our enum every single time we
call the equals
but if the other thing we're looking at
is also an enum we're also boxing that
as well so we're actually boxing both
both sides of this equation at a given
time
whoops so really simple mistake we were
just using the the nor the standard
equals method and just assuming that
that would be safe but no it actually
was not in this case and thankfully uh
yeah jetbrain's Dynamic profiler helped
us find that
so we rewrote this code
and I'll zoom in a little bit to make
that a little easier to read we rewrote
this code
to use the equality compare and we pass
in the type the generic type that users
use to create these FSM actors so
quality
compare.default.equals and this actually
performs a non-boxing check on both of
these enums here it's basically doing an
integer comparison on both of them now
that way we don't allocate anything
anymore
so if I take a look at my note here this
removed 100 of boxing allocations at
this call site and helped speed up this
comparison operation really
significantly by an order of magnitude
or more
so again a really simple type of mistake
that's really easy for developers to
make and a really good tool like the
dynamic profiler and Rider can help you
find this stuff uh when you're running
your applications
here's where things get a little tricky
which is we actually have a built-in
value type in akka.net that's used
really heavily today called an envelope
this is what we use to do in-memory
message passing from one actor to
another so we produce
potentially hundreds of millions of
these a second depending on how busy
your system is and this today already
exists as a read-only struct
well what happens when a value type
passes from one method to another and
you're not using a ref keyword on there
well the answer is that you copy it
right this basic result if you're
passing an integer around through
multiple methods you're copying it by
value rather than copying by reference
this is something you might have learned
you know in a introductory course an
object-oriented programming with C plus
plus C sharp or Java maybe those are
sort of the semantics for how value
types in C sharp work well this envelope
is highly concurrent and gets passed
around between lots of different actors
and appears in lots of different
mailboxes and there's going to be a lot
of copying pressure happening throughout
the system on here so one Theory we had
was what happens if we go and change
this back to a reference type could that
actually be faster in this case because
we're not constantly having to make
copies of this data structure over and
over again implicitly by moving messages
throughout our pipeline so we thought
okay we're super mega Geniuses let's go
ahead and see if this works
so what our current sort of Baseline
performance looks like in aka.net with
this read-only struct is if we have an
actor processing a million messages and
this is using the other performance
improvements you saw earlier it takes us
about
um you know for Su for ten thousand
messages it's about 2.2 milliseconds and
then for a hundred thousand messages
it's about 9.8 milliseconds okay
let's see what happens when we change
this back to a reference type so if we
zoom in here oops sorry about that I've
made this back into a uh yeah a sealed
class and what do the numbers look like
well this actually reduce allocations
and if I zoom out over here
in fact it sure did reduce allocations
specifically when we're enqueuing
messages inside the mailbox so memory
pressure actually went down as a result
of moving from a value type to a
reference type since we're not doing all
that copying pressure over and over
again so we went from let's say about
yeah 394 kilobits to 264 or from 3.15
megabytes to 2.1 megabytes great this
feels like an amazing win I'm going to
go ahead and write a blog post and get
an MVP award for sure
but wait there's more
it's not quite that simple
member of my team
you know who understands all this stuff
says yeah copy by value has its pitfalls
it can result in a lot of pressure when
you're moving that same data structure
through a lot of different contexts he
says yes
that is all true Aaron and you have
proved that proven this using this
single threaded Benchmark very well done
however
have you considered have you considered
what happens when we start running this
the way we really do in aka.net which is
across a lot of threads where we're
going to be passing these value types
around not just on a single thread in a
benchmark.net benchmark but across
potentially you know in a really large
application it might be a hundred
threads or it might be 30 or 40. what
happens to that same Benchmark when we
significantly increase cross thread
message traffic
and I said all right game on I'll go
ahead and test this I'm sure my MVP
award is good so I go ahead and run this
little Benchmark here
uh but we're putting let's see about a
hundred thousand messages through and
I'm keeping track of my gen zero and gen
1 allocations here and so it looks like
we allocated with um my c-sharp uh
reference types here about 104 megabytes
when we were doing let's say 10 total
actors and when I had 100 actors we did
you know 10 roughly 10x that about a
gigabyte of memory okay that looks good
I can see my total throughput here uh
was about on average took about 1.2
seconds for 10 actors to process a
hundred thousand messages each and it's
like 100 actors roughly 10x that roughly
13 seconds
now what happens if we convert an
envelope back into a struct again
well if we take a look at the memory
usage memory usage is way down now that
we're back into a concurrent context we
went from 104 megabytes back to 71 from
about a gig back into 689 again it's
that 32-bit allocation disappearing
again that's sort of what happened here
and on top of that
if I take a look at our performance our
performance was essentially unaffected
by changing this from a value type to a
reference type either way it was only
the amount of memory utilization that
really got affected by it so the sort of
lesson here if I zoom back out sorry for
my AV my Boomer AV challenges today is
guys this is uh
all kind of doing it on the Fly here
um the issue in this case is that
something that looks like it works in a
single threaded context may not
necessarily be so in a multi-threaded
context because the way memory gets
copied between cores and the way context
switching works also has an impact on
the ultimate throughput and the ultimate
so let's say sort of effectiveness of
some of these Solutions so lesson
learned
changing a value type into a reference
type well it worked great on a single
core absolutely sucked when we did it on
a multi-core system and so we move on to
the next section threads hate you and
your code
so let's go ahead and talk a little bit
about memory management in a
multi-threaded environment
um c-sharp has these Concepts called
thread static and thread local variables
and there's also async local which is a
little different and we'll talk about
that
what these Concepts kind of have in
common the thread local and thread
static is they allocate objects directly
into what's known as thread local
storage so this is data that's being
allocated inside a special area reserved
for that thread and that's really useful
for storing things like potentially
a bit of work you know that one thread
is going to need to refer to over and
over again so an example in akka.net
where we use thread static values is we
have a a last recently at least recently
used cash lru cash for storing a
deserialized actor paths and we use that
rather than a concurrent dictionary
because we can avoid having to
synchronize cash values between all the
different cores that are currently doing
work on processing those remoting
workloads at any given time having a
thread local construct is inherently
thread safe because no one else can
access those values although in theory
you can but it's super awkward and weird
so it's probably very unlikely to happen
and then on top of that all the data and
work that's being performed while that
thread is running are kind of in an
adjacent registers and memory for that
stack
so the downside of thread local data
structures is that they can't be
synchronized uh by Def by definition you
could create a a thread static
concurrent dictionary if you wanted to
but that concurrent dictionary couldn't
very easily be referenced by any other
thread so these sort of thread static
constructs are useful
in context where you're you know you're
going to be performing work on the same
thread over and over again and that
works all going to look quite similar
so this kind of brings us to dotnet's
threading model and the impact this
might have on your application's
performance
reference types that get passed between
let's say uh activities running on
separate threads they're almost always
going to end up in gen 2. not always
sometimes you might end up in gen 1 but
typically it's going to end up in gen 2.
so if you
invoke an a weights and you passed in
some data into that and that object is
going to get used inside that awaitable
method more often than not that bit of
data you passed in there is going to get
promoted to Gen 2 garbage collection
value types that are passed between
threads are simply copied into the stack
of the new thread that's there that's
why the memory allocation pressure from
our multi-threaded Benchmark actually
went down is because basically we were
making these sort of uh stack stack
based copies of those objects over and
over again versus allocating new ones on
the Heap and then trying to move that
stuff across different uh different CPUs
where the performance sort of
characteristics for multi-threading
start to become really relevant is the
higher i o levels that your computer can
run at namely taking advantage of L1 and
L2 caching these are the the built-in
memory caches that your actual physical
CPUs themselves have access to and they
tend to be quite small so maybe it might
be the L2 cache might have 16 or maybe
on a really big processor maybe 32 and
then your L1 cache is going to be an
order magnitude smaller than that so
maybe four megabytes or so but these
have much faster access speeds than even
dram does on your machine
one of the things that we can typically
take advantage of is that if we have the
same types of work being performed by
the same thread and that same thread is
getting scheduled on the same CPU over
and over again the hardware will begin
to optimize the memory access to start
moving some of those frequently accessed
objects or those frequently accessed
methods into those cache lines and that
will allow your application to execute
many orders of magnitude faster for that
little bit of code but that kind of
relies on a little bit of what's called
we call sort of thread locality where
the thread is being scheduled onto the
same core over and over again
most operating systems and also the.net
runtime will by default try to do that
for you so the underlying infrastructure
is going to try to do a good job out of
the game
however it's still possible for your
application to experience context
switching context switching is what
happens when work was executing on one
thread let's say you have a long IAC
enumerable you're iterating through you
might go ahead and process a couple of
your a-weighted operations on thread a
which is running on
um one CPU and then when you a weight
maybe that thread has to go service some
other work that's more urgent and then
another thread running on another CPU is
going to be the one that gets scheduled
to pick up uh the next a weight in your
chain that is called a context switch
when that occurs
basically
what's going to happen is that each
thread in and this is kind of scoped
more or less to Windows but the Linux
sort of runtime works very similar to
this where each thread is given by the
operating system a what's called a
Quantum of time to work with and that's
usually bounded to about 30 milliseconds
of execution time this value is
configurable and also can be different
between something like Windows desktop
and Windows Server so it kind of can
vary a little bit but this is generally
speaking how all preemptive operating
systems are designed where each thread
is given a finite amount of time and we
do this in order to prevent starvation
so one really long running task crowding
out shorter ones so that thread is going
to get scheduled onto the CPU
and after it completes its work or after
it basically consumes it's allotted time
that thread will get moved to the back
of the operating system's work queue and
the next thread that is scheduled to run
on that CPU will get its Quantum of time
and the operating system is going to be
constantly kind of managing this and
linearizing work where it's possible and
it's going to try to make sure the same
threads get scheduled onto the same CPU
but there's no guarantees it's a little
arbitrary in terms of how it can work
context switching is when thread 0 moves
onto a different CPU or in this case
your a weighted unit of work was being
processed on thread zero but now it's
being processed on thread four those
types those are both examples of context
switching we're essentially the runtime
execution context of your piece of code
is being changed up from under you
usually through arbitrary things like
whichever core whichever thread was
available you don't necessarily have a
lot of control over that as a software
developer
well
as it turns out we actually do have some
control over this beginning like dot net
core 3.3.0 and I believe
um I believe the actual task work queue
for scheduling uh TPL tasks actually
does use this under the covers now but
we're getting a net core three they
added a new interface called an i thread
pool work item this was an interface
that basically allowed us to go ahead
and schedule work directly on the thread
pool without needing to create a bunch
of weird little callback delegates and
stuff like that it could basically just
be in any arbitrary class that
implements this interface can now be
scheduled directly onto the.net thread
pool
well there's also another new API they
added in.net6 and I'll go ahead and use
my Boomer Zoom here let's get this up
and running
all right there we go maybe a little
bigger a little bigger all right there
we go
this is a relatively new API they added
in.net6 thread pool to unsafe Q user
work item that's like that that method's
been around for a long time what's new
is this little parameter right here
which is totally unreadable with me
being zoomed in here but basically what
this parameter does is it specifies
for this particular I runnable work item
I would prefer to reschedule it onto the
same CPU that I am running on right now
if possible
uh I don't think I have a diagram on
this but essentially every single thread
in the.net thread pool has like a local
work queue and threads have the ability
to steal work items from each other in
order to try to keep the system
um moving smoothly at all times so that
way tasks don't wait a long time to get
executed what this actual uh call does
is it cues this work item right now onto
the thread that's currently executing
and guess what if you have something
like an actor that constantly schedules
itself over and over again to keep
processing messages in its mailbox that
means that actor is going to have a lot
less context switching as a result of
this it's going to always essentially
provide a hint to the runtime that I
want to execute on the same thread that
I'm currently running on right now and
so long as there isn't some major
starvation or crowding issue or some
other
um arbitrary semantic run time issue
that would prevent this from working
what we're going to end up experiencing
is a pretty significant impact on
performance
so if we take a look here at our little
performance comparison
in fact I got to use the zoom again pull
this out
this is awka.net's in-memory messaging
Benchmark and I think this is running
on.net6
um before we added that API call and
after we added the API call so we have
two different types of actors we're
benchmarking here let's just take a look
at the actor base on the left we're
doing at about Peak throughput and that
throughput value by the way on the left
is basically saying how many birth like
how big of a burst of messages can an
actor process at any given time so when
an actor gets scheduled to run we have
the ability to configure how many
messages an actor can process the
default value is 30 which is a pretty
good handles like 99 of use cases so a
throughput of one means this actor is
going to have the highest possible
context switching a throughput of 900
means while this actor is not going to
have very much context switching at all
it's also going to hog threads for a
really long time so it's kind of a
little bit of a balance to strike there
so let's take a look at the throughput
value of 30 which is our system default
we're doing about 41 million messages a
second on you
know.net.net6 before we added that API
life
once we add that API we jump from about
40 million messages a second to 65
million messages a second so that's um
now I'm a little jet lagged and I had a
lot of beer last night but I think
that's about a 50 increase in overall
memory throughput if my mental math
serves me well that is a tremendous free
lunch for an aqua.net user that they
didn't really have to do a lot of work
for all we had to do was find a way from
an infrastructure point of view to
reduce context switching
um there's apis you can go ahead and
call directly just like the ones I
showed you for doing this but generally
speaking the way a lot of the TPL stuff
is designed in newer versions of.net
will automatically help do a lot of this
for you now make sure that your tasks
get rescheduled back under the thread
that's currently servicing them it's not
a guarantee but it's a preference you
can go up that will be set automatically
whenever you go ahead and a weight a
task usually so if you haven't upgraded
to newer versions of.net you should
definitely consider doing that in order
to take advantage of it
uh let's see
move on to the next slide here
thread locality without context
switching yeah we kind of covered that
all right
data structures and synchronization so
one thing we decided that we thought we
could do being the super mega Geniuses
that we are was maybe we could
outperform the.net runtime at managing a
concurrent Cube sure that seems like a
trivial problem I could hack together in
an afternoon right
yeah I'm being sarcastic the concurrent
cue is very very well done
um so I I thought to myself you know uh
we could in theory maybe use a linked
list and reduce some of the internal
allocations that happen with lots of
messages are being queued into the same
actor at the same time so why don't we
go ahead and try using a linked list
with a lock and see how well that works
well if we take a look at the
performance numbers for what this looked
like earlier
we can see that you know our and Q
performance we're allocating about 385k
and it takes us about 200 microseconds
to encue 10 000 messages into a single
mailbox okay all right that's sort of
our Baseline got it
well what happens if I go and change it
to a synchronized linked list with a
lock like this locks are relatively
cheap from a a synchronization
standpoint they're not free but they're
not tremendously expensive either so I'm
going to go ahead and use the built-in
linked list and
system.collections.generic and I'm going
to place a lock around all the sort of
mutable operations on it internally
and I'm thinking this should offer
better performance than a concurrent
queue because I can go ahead and easily
append new items to the end of the list
and easily consume items from the front
of the list without having to resize the
internal Collections and the internal
memory segments that are concurrent
queue uses let's see how well that
worked out in theory
well
um if I zoom in here
we got our asses kicked more or less
um not only did we double the amount of
memory usage that we had before we also
more than doubled the amount of latency
that we had so if I were a Ruby
programmer I consider this to be a job
well done and check it in and move on
but instead we went ahead and rolled
that back and decided you know what
we're probably better off just waiting
for the very smart people the.net
runtime to make keep working on
concurrent queue and improving that for
us each time
so what went wrong there
well basically the concurrent queue is
actually a lock free data structure this
is the sort of stuff that you can go
ahead and write for fun if you want to
but it's very difficult to get right in
practice thankfully concurrent cues got
a ton of people using it therefore a lot
of regression testing a lot of really
smart computer science type people
looking at it it uses basically volatile
memory to go ahead and swap out sections
of its internal sort of buffers
internally and it uses some Lock Free
synchronization methods like interlock
stock compare exchange to do this it's
very optimized for lots of quick reads
and writes from both the back of the
queue and the front of the queue
happening concurrently it is
significantly less expensive even on a
single thread to use this than it is to
use a lock inside of there on top of
that I'm pretty sure.net's built-in
linked list is utter crap and you would
have been way better off writing your
own like linked list implementation
using pointers basically than doing that
so I'm convinced that the linked list
data structure on its own was probably a
bad choice uh for us but nevertheless
the fact that the Locking overhead was
so high and we observed that in our
tests meant that we should probably just
stick with concurrent queue for the time
being
now the last thing I'm going to touch on
before we run out of time here is a
brand new feature that kind of made it
into.net 7 and will be available by
default in.net 8 going forward which is
dynamic profile guided optimization this
is a just-in-time compiler setting for
net
uh this is the second big win I told you
about
pgo which you'll see This Acronym appear
in like your configuration and also in
some of the literature on.net profile
guided optimization is basically where
the compiler or sorry the just-in-time
compiler analyzes how your program runs
while it's running and makes decisions
about how can we speed up some of these
frequently used areas of code
essentially the the just-in-time
compiler will make a bet and see how it
goes and if that bet results in higher
throughput it'll keep that byte code
around the next time through
there's two different types of profile
guided optimization there's static pgo
which has been around I think this
is.net five they've had some flavor of
this this analyzes the program when it's
not running and makes some optimization
decisions ahead of time this is that
cold start reduction you've heard about
so this was designed to kind of help
things like serverless functions launch
more quickly on Azure that type of thing
that's what static pgo does and that's
kind of a jit function that takes
runtime data and makes it available
offline to help speed up the reduced
cold start times but the really exciting
feature is dynamic pgo this is new
in.net6 or sorry.net seven and will be
made available by turned on by default
in.net 8. this is the ability for the
jit to optimize your program while it's
running based on real usage patterns
from live interactions with users or
other systems
let's take a look at it
um
the cost of turning on profile guided
optimization nothing is free in the
software development industry
um the cost of turning on profile guided
optimization is that the amount of
resources your just-in-time compiler is
going to use will probably go up by a
factor of three so in this case I used a
perf view to go ahead and measure this I
was able to compute the total amount of
time my application spent in jit so when
I had pgo turned off I think I spent a
total of 0.5 percent of CPU running the
just-in-time compiler so out of all the
things my application was doing half a
percent of it was just-in-time
compilation when I turned on Dynamic pgo
that value jumped from 0.5 to 1.1
percent so you know more than 100
increase in just-in-time compiling time
in terms of raw milliseconds of you know
computation time that used that's going
from like roughly two seconds to 3.1
seconds is sort of roughly held that
sort of in terms of uh practical terms
and this is for an application that ran
for many minutes so it's even though
that percent increase sounds big in the
grand scheme of things it practically
speaking was not noticeable
but the performance impact this had in
our application was tremendous okay take
us take a photograph of this Implement
both of these settings in your server
apps when you get home this is the money
slide this by itself is worth it's worth
the time time to attend
this will turn on uh Dynamic profile
guided optimization the setting above
that turns on server-side garbage
collection that's the money shot
um you won't need to do the tiered pgo
setting anymore starting with DOT net a
it'll just be enabled by default going
forward
now we went ahead and benchmarked some
of our code with pgo turned on and off
so we actually compared the performance
of two actors uh the dotted line is our
receive actor which uses all sorts of
fancy expression compiler magic to try
to be fast this is like clever 2014 era
like performance optimizations whereas
the untyped actor which is the solid
line you can see up there uses c-sharp
pattern matching essentially just
built-in language features nothing fancy
at all so on.net6 the performance of
these two over let's say a large range
of messages is roughly equal not there's
not no real clear Divergence in
performance here
and in.net 7 again the performance is
roughly equal there's a little bit of a
outlier at the very end down there but
we can kind of disregard that I wouldn't
count that as statistically significant
but when I turn on profile guided
optimization there's a really clear
Trend that the untyped actor that's
using switch expressions and pattern
matching versus our super duper smart
receive actor that uses delegates and
caching and the expression compiler you
can actually see the r code that is
simple is significantly faster than our
code smart code this is because the
dynamic pgo system is able to actually
interpret and understand the simple code
that we wrote and is able to make that
much faster at runtime whereas our quote
smart unquote optimizations and the
receive actor are things that the
dynamic profile guided optimization
system looks at and goes
well these dudes are pretty weird we're
going to skip that code and because we
don't know what we're there's too much
going on here we're not going to try to
optimize it so this kind of changes The
Meta for how we want to do Performance
Management and Dot net to some extent
simpler constructs that use built-in
language features are going to be made a
lot faster as a result of dynamic pgo
and the types of optimizations this
includes are things like removing
interface dispatching overhead
devirtualizing methods so essentially
there's less function tables and things
like that for figuring out which
implementation of a method should be
called and all sorts of things and we
can see an example of what the
cumulative impact of that looks like on
our performance this is our Benchmark
for aqued.net 1.5's in-memory message
processing without pgo turned on on.net
seven and we're peeking out around 70
million messages per second here
bear in mind we're taking advantage of
that
prefer local API we saw earlier to
reduce context switching so we're doing
about 70 million messages a second
well if I turn Dynamic pgo on now we're
doing about 100 million messages per
second Peak Performance and you can kind
of see that around let's say yeah 40 uh
one of the throughput is set to about 40
or 90. you can see that show up so this
is a free lunch for us as.net developers
all I have to do is hand over a few more
CPU Cycles to the Justin Time compiler
and enable one XML setting and I get a
you know 30 40 performance Improvement
that sounds like a pretty good deal
um on top of that I didn't I didn't
include this Benchmark on here just in
the interest of time but our remoting
pipeline where we're doing Network i o
is actually twice as fast what dynamic
pgo turned on so we go from about 300
000 messages a second to about six or
seven hundred thousand messages a second
with Dynamic pgo enabled so this is
quite the free lunch for net developers
this will be enabled by default.net 8
which should come out uh November this
year probably but you can go ahead and
turn it on and start reaping some of the
benefits and measuring it in your own
applications in.net 7 today using that
slide I showed you
so I know we just ran a few minutes over
but I'll Stick Around Here For questions
for a couple minutes and then I'll make
way for the next speaker and head
outside but otherwise I want to thank
everyone for attending my talk today
really appreciate your time and I hope
you enjoyed it thank you
[Applause]